everybody what's going on blade here and
we're at the Irish American Heritage
Center here in Chicago Illinois for the
behind the scenes of the Irish
step-dancing
remote let's go inside and see if Conan
has what it takes with the Irish
Historical Society the Irish heritage
Historical Society or the historical
heritage Society of Ireland one of those
just taken apart brick by brick
this is Bono's pizza oven was brought
here from Dublin and reassembled the
band u2 used to practice there's a small
impact
we're proud to show off Highlands with
his technological leaps and is just
coming out with this it's their version
of the iPad this is the way to sweat
that they're using my return I can get
you will be beta an amazing you of
course could be an Irish best well it's
decided about far there's children here
there's a part in this round
[Music]
[Music]
when the irish-american Heritage Center
purchased this school the first thing
they did was they ripped out the library
and install this bar right over here
there's a second bar okay and this is
mostly used for preschoolers but also
k43 it's up here a product what are we
just finished doing tour of course we're
a bar they lived up to the Irish name is
six bars and drink anywhere it's awesome
right now we're in a giant bowling
it's pretty great all the drunken Irish
people weddings in this we do just hose
off the floor thing it's awesome and now
what we're gonna do I think we're gonna
go do some step dance let's make it
happen let's do it
[Music]
the legs legs I would think of my strong
suit their long time you know I'm sorry
cartoons8 cartoons the Irish jig is
always you know this is what I kinda get
it we don't know what this is you know
what I mean when I think of a guy
finding gold
[Music]
[Music]
I think you should just have the
drumming keep going okay so you don't
want the finality of any point just keep
y'all yeah cuz I can just come out and
do my presentation whole life
[Music]
and we're gonna get you a slow-mo with
me kicking you now you're a pro you keep
going let's look great everybody I'm
here with Rico Martin right there's a
piece Lord what do you think oh man I
think this is gonna be epic this is your
first remotely first ring man and how
would you learn we stumbled into some
great stuff that we didn't expect
which will take some good degree
realistic to see this Scott he made it
all right chronic done with the Irish
stepdance remote how do you think it
went
it was hilarious actually it was really
funny I can't believe those kids there I
know really really great shape I can't
even touch my toes - toes either all
right well thanks for watching guys and
I know we'll see you next time adios
adios
[Music]